hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
October 31st 2022.
2022 what's going on everybody how are
you
um yes it's Halloween all right and if
you're an adult do yourself a favor let
the kids dress up
stay out of it
all right
all kinds of you know cute things happen
when kids dress up as their favorite you
know superhero cartoon character or
whatnot when adults do it you know all
of a sudden somebody makes a pass to
somebody's [ __ ] wife somebody wears
something socially uh not correct and
goes to work and gets a dumbass fired
you know
don't do that don't go Eyes Wide Shut
don't [ __ ] show up in a clan suit
being like no I'm not in the clan I was
dressed I'm dressing as someone in the
clan
what do you mean I can't manage it
um
you can't manage a restaurant wearing
that it's a Crackle Barrel
um yeah
I'm not saying you can't go out there
and just [ __ ] you know
do whatever the [ __ ] you want to do not
saying that not trying to wag my finger
at you
okay
is all this phonies out here in
Hollywood love to do we love to tell you
how to live your lives don't we huh
you guys online with your simple Country
Boys
leave me alone my gun to my [ __ ] pigs
uh none of that's true
no that's true those are just the
stereotypes
um
the reality is this most people tell
other people how they should be [ __ ]
livid
you know and they're called motivational
speakers
foreign
you know I miss
I miss the guys late at night that would
be screaming
about whatever product they were trying
to sell to the point
like they they did
veins would be popping out of their
[ __ ] necks
remember that guy I don't even know what
he was selling
I just remember he had long blonde hair
that he had I think in a ponytail and he
would just be screaming
actually a bit about that guy like 25
years ago the [ __ ] guy was always
selling something
maybe talking to somebody then they
would be speaking in a regular voice and
he would just be screaming at them about
whatever the latest hunk of [ __ ] that he
was selling
whatever happened to that guys anybody
know where that guy I hope that guy's
guy still has his money because there's
no way he still has his voice
the only person I ever saw scream
like longer than that guy consistently
on my television was Brian Johnson of AC
DC
um
anyway so it's Halloween uh gonna take
my daughter out I want to take my son
out too but my uh my wife thinks she's
he's too young
um which I don't know I don't think so
I guess he'd want to like run around and
[ __ ] who knows my kids are still like
young so like we go out earlier
um
I still remember when my daughter was
three
and we were going out trick-or-treating
we were having a great time
and um
I said to her at one point I go how you
doing buddy how you doing
and she goes she goes I'm doing good she
goes dada
I'm not tired I'm not tired like she
knew she felt me trying to wrap it up
and I was just like oh wow okay
she [ __ ] is loving this and is on to
what I'm trying to do so we went to like
you know
20 more houses came home with all of
this candy
it's funny and she eats her candy the
way
I guess my wife did when she was a
little girl
where I guess
my lovely wife would try to make it last
as long as she could
and she would still be eating it and
snacking on it and like March
which is weird to me maybe it wasn't
that long
I on the other hand would go home and
like that night just begin just you know
my parents would be like you can have
one piece of candy and then go to bed
right the [ __ ]
the rules right
so we would do that and then like you
know the next morning we wake up before
they even knew it we already had like
[ __ ]
five pieces of candy
you know oh it's [ __ ] Charleston chew
all those shitty [ __ ]
just candy bars I feel like are way
better
like there was some really bad ones like
Charleston chew was [ __ ] terrible I
don't know what I don't even know what
was in it
it was chocolate sort of on the outside
it had some sort of white filling that
wasn't quite marshmallow and it wasn't
quite like
nougat
like did they even use nougat anymore
that's like one of those like man-made
things
um
anyway I'm just saying you know don't go
to work as a woman dressed as a [ __ ]
prostitute
all right because some guy's gonna say
something and then you know I know
you're not a prostitute but whatever you
know
this is comedian Symphony Cynthia Corey
used to do this [ __ ] bit it's a
Timeless joke
I first saw her do it in the late 90s
was talking about women
I think you know walking around going
I'm a cat I'm a cat she's like no you're
a [ __ ]
[Music]
just coming in with like no [ __ ]
clothes on it's one of my favorite
[ __ ]
like just like the very few Timeless
jokes but you could do that joke today
you could do it 25 years ago you
probably could have done it in the 70s
um
anyway
um
plowing ahead here uh old freckles all
freckles watched a little bit of sports
this weekend
um I watched game one of the World
Series
and as still they have not brought up
the [ __ ] Astros that the Astros fixed
the [ __ ] World Series
um so I started trolling them on the
[ __ ] uh
on the internet just on on Twitter just
to get it going let's get it come on man
you got to get it going let's let's
let's get give them the [ __ ] that they
[ __ ] deserve now here's the deal like
you know
I don't give a [ __ ] that they did it
what I give a [ __ ] about is that people
aren't still talking about it okay
because I watch my team like trumped up
charges like complete horseshit that got
[ __ ] thrown out of court lasted for
[ __ ] 10 years
oh they filmed the Rams practice we
Never filmed it it was complete
horseshit everyone knew it was horseshit
they kept reporting it and then six
years later after [ __ ] talking about
it the goddamn ESPN does a [ __ ] tweet
at two in the two in the morning
retracting it
these guys fix the [ __ ] world series
I mean they got to be getting their [ __ ]
they the storyline is the Houston Astros
are trying to win their first World
Series without cheating and this is what
gets even better turns out one of the
guys on the Astros
in the first game was using a bat that
was illegal
okay now some are saying it's because
the head was too big and other was
saying because it's a dangerous wood and
it could Splinter that's what Astro fans
are saying
you know some MLB guy like stated that
and then quickly retracted it for
whatever [ __ ] reason so who knows
what and then the pitcher last night was
wiping all kinds of goop off of his
[ __ ] wrist
uh I mean that just a dirty filthy nasty
little franchise aren't they
I'm enjoying every second of this and
they were up five to nothing and the
baseball God said you guys cheat too
much and they lost that [ __ ] game
that the Phillies came back uh that's
the one thing I would be nervous about
if I was a an astro if I was rooting for
the team that fixed the first World
Series since uh 1919 when the Chicago
White Sox did it
um
I would be worried that uh the the
Phillies
Beat Justin Verlander and
they don't quit like last night they
were down five to one still got a guy in
base still brought him in
still scoring runs in the ninth still
kind of making Astro fans uncomfortable
um
I I gotta be honest with you like when
the Astros got caught I didn't give a
[ __ ] because of all the steroids and and
that type of [ __ ] so I was hey you know
good on you whatever you banged on a
trash can good for you my thing is you
should be getting [ __ ] for it and then I
met some Astro fans and the way that
they were blowing off what happened
the way that they were blowing up like
you literally fixed a World Series
everybody does it everybody does it it's
like no they don't they don't
you know everybody took steroids
everybody if they had the money you know
loaded up on free agents everybody
didn't [ __ ] do what you guys did
[Laughter]
um
so that's all it is I just want to see
them get their [ __ ] and uh I've been
enjoying the hell out it's actually been
a really good series and as far as be
honest with you as far as a a pitcher
was you know putting stuff on the ball
that is something they all do and
hitters actually appreciate it because
they don't they want the guy to have
some control
you know if somebody gets update like
wild thing and hits you in the head you
can end your career or your [ __ ] life
so as far as I know I don't think
baseball players have that big a uh
issue with it but um I think the
Phillies are are yeah I think it all
depends
I think it all depends on what's going
on
but um
I don't know I don't I don't know what
but I am enjoying that the fans are at
least talking about it and I am
absolutely astounded that ESPN has not
said a [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] word
about it and they drag the Patriots for
20 [ __ ] years
not 20 years from 07 right up until Tom
Brady left
um
and then Tom Brady leaves and wins the
title and then they all start going uh
is Bill Belichick nothing without them
um
I don't know
did it really come down to the fact that
Tom Brady was a good looking guy
um I think a lot of it did because the
the [ __ ] Joy that people are getting
watching him having a tough season
and uh ripping him apart and then
enjoying watching him go through a
divorce
is bizarre
um like who who's [ __ ] happy that
somebody's going through a divorce
you know or looks at it like oh there
this you know the next four hours of
this radio program right itself
um
and then also the amount of people that
like uh
I don't know they give a [ __ ] about
athletes personal lives like that like
you're supposed to be into sports you're
not supposed to be into the Real
Housewife [ __ ] so why would you give a
[ __ ] about what this person you know
it's not like anything crazy happened
he's getting a divorce who gives a [ __ ]
it's none of your business
like leave the guy alone
um leave Brittany alone
um so anyway I uh watched
yeah I watched that first game
and then I was clicking back and forth
just sort of watching the score in game
two because I was watching Michigan
versus Michigan State
and um
I love that game that was a great big
ten game couldn't score a touchdown
kicked a field goals John Madden
football
I loved it right and uh one of the
announcers was going like
these field goals better figure out how
to make them touchdowns they're only
gonna have a tough time against Ohio
State it's like they're not playing Ohio
State right now
and they're taking what Michigan state
is giving them a team that beat him two
the last two years in a row
and they're making the field goals and
they're the these field goals is what's
making them win the [ __ ] game like I
don't understand at what point the field
goal
became like
like this loser move like getting three
points is a bad move and you should just
go for it and and you know push all your
chips in every [ __ ] hand you dealt I
just don't [ __ ] understand it Paul
Brown back in the day with Lou the
tobrosa
they changed football they showed how
important the kicking game is and now
they're literally trying to [ __ ] get
rid of it they're almost trying to get
rid of the punter now do you go for it
here in the first quarter rather than
going three and out on your own 18. I'll
tell you right now it wouldn't surprise
me at third and 12 on their own [ __ ]
18 in the first quarter uh I'm surprised
they didn't go for it right there
[ __ ] Madness
um
I haven't said that uh by the way it was
a great game
um
it's just great to see that Michigan
stuck with uh Jim Harbaugh and he's
brought the program back
and that the the Michigan Ohio State
game is going to be this great
competitive game and it has been since
he's been there especially with that
[ __ ] up spot they gave him
um back in the day
um although now they have the replay
because they gave they [ __ ] Michigan
on a spot in the first quarter on a
fourth down
and um
they went to replay and they got it
right so we shall see
um Ohio State played yesterday they
didn't actually have an easy game so I
don't know why that guy was talking
about like how you know going down the
field and putting points up on the board
was somehow a bad thing
um
you know like that we would be somehow
losing to Ohio State it's like it's
going to be a completely different game
if we're playing Ohio State and we're
losing to Ohio State
and every time we go down the field we
kick a field goal rather than get a
touchdown I understand saying it then
but when you're playing Michigan State
and each time you kick a field goal you
put another three points between them
and you thus increasing your chances of
winning the game I don't understand like
even now when you kick a field goal and
you're winning they're going like hell
you go
you gotta get a touchdown there I mean
we gotta we gotta start getting these
these field goals gotta be touchdowns
it's like we're winning we're winning
the fight you play to win the game
um
anyway so I was flicking back and forth
I was mainly watching that
that game and uh watched it right
through like the third quarter and then
I went outside and uh
took an old man walk as I did
uh underrated the fall out here in La
the couple of weeks that we have of it
now is nice
um
did I watch anything else
uh I have no idea but I will say this I
think if the whoever wins the next game
wins the World Series
that's what I think
Phillies just have to be up in this
uh
I just feel like they're down to one
they lose two in a row and then they got
Verlander coming back for another one I
just don't see it
I think uh the Astros are playing
catch-up
um
that's the position that they want to be
in I know they came back in game one I
don't think that they can they can do
that in a game
I don't know [ __ ] about either team but
like
I don't know everybody talks about game
five being important I mean they're all
important
but uh I think it's
I think the Phillies really need to be
in the driver's seat there's another
thing too is [ __ ] altube hasn't hit
[ __ ] [ __ ] until last night
until last night so the story would be
like wow you know it's kind of amazing
when they were banging on that [ __ ]
trash can you know what was coming
during your home games yeah I mean you
you were you were like an All-Star
you know and then last night they're
just going like he went he got three
hits he's back
it's like all right all right this is
just me
you know being a [ __ ] because all you
guys including fans of the Houston
Astros you guys all sat back and you let
that [ __ ] drug addict piece of [ __ ]
Jimmer say slander our [ __ ] team and
you guys all went along with it because
none of you could beat us other than the
[ __ ] Giants and I never heard any
[ __ ] coming from the [ __ ] Giants
okay they just went out and beat us
that's what the [ __ ] they did
oh you other [ __ ] [ __ ] Seth his
shoe strings you you you're not
regulation
all right sorry I'm gonna end I'm gonna
I'm gonna stop
I'm gonna stop right there okay before
before it starts to get ugly
um
anyway I've been uh oh Patriots beat the
Jets I did I did mention that I I uh
I I saw some of that game I I just spent
um
I've been trying to go to the gym every
day and uh
and now I I just I don't know I overdid
it with the coffee the other day like
two days in a row I had a cappuccino and
then I got a double espresso later on
the day I did that I know I know I know
there's a bunch of coffee drinkers going
dude dude what the [ __ ] are you doing so
I went to bed Friday night and I was
just Restless all night with like this
ambiguous anxiousness
and the only thing I can attribute it to
was like I was having a panic attack but
I wasn't freaking out about anything
and the only thing I could attribute it
to was was drinking too much of that
[ __ ] caffeine
and I haven't touched the stuff since
and I don't [ __ ] miss it
and
um
I don't think it's good for you
I think every once in a while
if you enjoy it it's all right
but
I think
when you need a nap and your brain's
saying I need to [ __ ] chill
to clear the cobwebs because you know
that feeling you get when you take a
quick cat nap like right before you take
the nap I mean you feel
your brain's in a fog and then you wake
up and you're fresh like your brain
needs that and the fact that you drink
coffee
and it it makes you plow through that
it's kind of like Coke
right or that Five Hour Energy [ __ ] all
of that stuff
is like
I'm tired now I'm not tired no you're
still tired your brain is still tired
it's just can no longer let you know
that
so I think in a way it's kind of uh
I find it like unsettling because we I
got some dementia in my family and
everything and I heard like naps
learning a new language learning an
instrument [ __ ] like that is good it's
good for your brain sort of like taking
your brain to the gym but I really think
like naps are are like a big thing and
um
you know
I think some people they get like uh
this Pride
that they don't want to be that older
guy who just nods off in a chair
you know you know those old people like
if you just [ __ ] put them in a chair
for too long they're like a dog tell a
dog to go lay down in the corner come on
get out of here come on go they lay down
like two seconds later they're sleeping
um
I think the more you act like a dog you
know I don't mean [ __ ] public
I mean there's sleep patterns
you know I just just make sure I clarify
that
[Music]
um
I think the more like you uh
you you do that the better and I think
when you get tired that's how I ended up
drinking coffee we were shooting the
movie and I was [ __ ] wiped out
and somebody goes you want a coffee
I was like I don't drink coffee you know
go wake you up
you know and like I just I I needed I
had you know I was working and we were
doing a late night so I said all right
what's uh cappuccino they go all right
they got it and I drank it I thought it
tasted kind of weird or whatever but all
of a sudden you know I air quote wasn't
tired again
I wasn't tired and then the next night I
drank it again and then uh
is kind of slow during like the edit
you know you're just sitting there
looking at this footage and your brain's
getting
tired trying to solve [ __ ] that you
don't have the skill set to solve
um
I just started drinking [ __ ] coffee
you know there was a couple of days I
was in the edit room and I just said to
the other people there going like listen
I'm just gonna shut my eyes for a second
and they just kept working and I
literally I can't like when I take a nap
I can't do like a half hour like I only
sleep for like six to eight minutes but
I did it
and I woke up
and I was [ __ ] fined for like the
next three hours so
this brings me back to what I was
talking about
with the myth of the siestas
in Spain and in Mexico and all of that
I could that would be amazing if
everybody could just not tease everybody
about their bed head when they came back
to work or whatever
um
that's just not how the corporate world
works and then corporate lawyers would
also scare the [ __ ] out of people going
like oh what's going to happen if
somebody's going to fall asleep and
somebody's going to get sexually
assaulted that's you'd have to spend all
this money
with pods where they could feel safe
that they could actually sleep next to
their co-worker they would just it's
going to be prohibitively expensive just
get a coffee machine that's okay that'll
be fine
um
anyway I have no idea what the [ __ ] I'm
even talking about at this point
um so anyway game three is coming up in
Nashville fence you know I'm just
[ __ ] breaking your balls
I'm breaking your balls because
you know they should be broken
and uh that one Astro fan I met where he
was every everybody does this everybody
doesn't do this
there's little things there is a little
that was a major major major [ __ ]
I mean look everybody cheats absolutely
but when you cheat at that [ __ ] level
that after they they catch you and they
punish people and then everybody just
shuts the [ __ ] up that's next level
cheating you're cheating [ __ ] with the
Integrity of the game that's what that
was
so [ __ ] you Astro fans all you guys
[ __ ] coming at me not liking that I'm
giving you a team [ __ ]
I'm having the same fun you were having
with trumped-up charges against the
Patriots
uh
uh so anyway
all right let's let's do the uh
let's do the re I've been doing all
right at the gym by the way
I have been I've been hitting the uh
hitting the elliptical and all of that
[ __ ] oh by the way next week if you're
not into college football get into
college football you got to watch
Tennessee versus Georgia
this is for the
number one [ __ ] see uh whatever
whatever ranking and King and tree
um Tennessee already [ __ ] handled
Alabama
and knocked them out of the playoff
right
so what sucks is Tennessee and Georgia
neither one of them is just going to put
Ohio State out of their misery
that's Michigan's job
but neither one of those teams are going
to beat Tennessee or [ __ ] Georgia or
possibly even Alabama like I don't know
what goes on in the SEC but it's just
played at a different [ __ ] level it
just is
um
all the other like football it just
looks like it's slower so anyway
Tennessee versus Georgia number one team
in the country versus the number three
team in the country uh Tennessee for my
money has the next Randy Moss
at wide wide receiver
um that kid Hilton and um
he already made Alabama look foolish so
I'm wondering what George is going to do
I wonder what their their defense is
like
I wonder how you keep that kid from
getting behind you
I mean he's the closest thing to just
uncoverable that I I've seen
um
in a while
and man if that kid has another big game
if he has another if he has a game
against Georgia
like he did with Alabama I mean he's
going to be like unless he's a big
quarterback coming out I would think he
would be
top three
right
is that what you would think yeah I'm a
comedian I don't [ __ ] know I don't
know things
um
anyway I read this book Soul on ice
and it just came because I saw a store
out here in Los Angeles called soul on
ice and it had all these cool sport
jerseys I haven't gone in it but I was
just driving by and I was like what the
oh I go um let me so I Googled it just
to see what they sold in there and then
I saw it was a classic book
written by this guy
that was in prison ended up joining the
Black Panthers and all of that
so I get the book and I start reading it
and uh the guys you know
talking about all those experiences
being a you know black guy and being in
prison and all that and then like he
went out and made a conscious choice to
become a rapist and I'm like what the
[ __ ] am I reading here
so I don't think I'm finished in that
book
I will list I will I have empathy until
you start raping people okay
foreign
classic
um
that's what kills me is that's what
that was the review it got
groundbreaking and all of that [ __ ] when
it first came out
um
the insights and all of that you know
which are there but at the end of the
day the guy made a decision to become a
race he says why he did and all that and
tries but I don't know
I don't know I can't I can't go with you
after that that's that's I'm getting off
at the next stop I'm out
foreign
anyway sorry just like I'm just whatever
I'm just talking about what's going on
in my life speaking of what's going on
in my life oh [ __ ] Billy [ __ ] feet
up
uh I've been
you know lazing about doing [ __ ] off as
they say over in England
um
I go I haven't been on the road in three
weeks I go back out
this week I'm gonna be uh in Peoria
Illinois hometown of the Great Richard
Pryor the greatest stand-up comedian
there ever was in my opinion uh I'm
playing Chicago and uh
that's free dates I don't know where the
next one is but
the tour sorry yawning here the tour is
winding down I got 13 dates left
and
um
then it's going to be freckles on ice
because I'm not doing [ __ ] I'm gonna
take a much needed break for a little
bit I don't know how long I'll
put you know knowing me it'll be about
about 10 days
and then I'll just start losing my mind
and I'll have to suck him start
doing something else but I'm going to
take a little bit of time off it's been
a great run I want to thank everybody
that's been buying tickets and coming
out to my shows
it's been uh it's been incredible so uh
thank you to everybody in advance who's
coming out to see me this weekend
I'm gonna say a bunch of dumb [ __ ] and I
hope I make you laugh all right with
that let's get to the uh
let's get to the the reads I got one
read here oh it's me undies everybody
beyondes me undies I will read your book
me undies me undies even if you are a
crook
but if you start raping people that's
when I'm out
I don't give a [ __ ] what you said I'm
gonna shout let me off at another the
next [ __ ] stop
I don't give a [ __ ] what you have to say
you [ __ ] rapist all right me undies
everybody the holidays are officially
upon us
and it's time to start celebrating like
actually celebrating it's part of the
copy
um it's your holiday too so you should
be able to relax and do what you love if
that means watching every single
seasonally themed rom-com so be it do
your thing and holiday and holiday your
way with me undies it's the most it's
the most wonderful time of the year to
try me undies because they're currently
offering a very merry deal get 20 off
your first purchase with free standard
shipping and free returns when you go to
meundies.com
get your holiday shopping finished early
and start making I haven't even [ __ ]
started
God damn it uh get your holiday shopping
finished early and start making time for
yourself with the new meundy's holiday
collection their undies loungewear and
sleepwear are made of the softest most
Supple fabric you've ever felt and are
guaranteed to bring comfort and joy to
all your loved ones shop their classic
plaid prints for a traditional
picture-perfect style or get festive
with their adventurous limited edition
uh sweater prints available in sizes XS
extra small sorry through 4XL yandis has
what you need to make all your favorite
people's all smile this holiday season
all in one convenient place feel free to
start thinking about yourself now to get
20 off your first order free shipping
and 100 satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com that's meundies.com slash
Burr there we go and with that
let's do the reads for this week
everybody Astros
and Astro fans writing it Bill correct
me if I'm wrong but didn't you go on
several rants that that the Astros
didn't do anything that bad
um no
that's not what I did he goes and I
quote they all do it I don't want to
hear about some jerk off hitting a trash
can when the Yankees bought half the
league and the Red Sox yes that's what I
said that's what I said
uh in the last few weeks you said and I
quote I mean they knew what pitch was
coming next here's where I extend my
handheld recording device in your
directions and say comments well I hope
you're listening
I hope you're listening this is my beef
is not that you [ __ ] cheated and
fixed a World Series because you did
I didn't give a [ __ ] that you did that
because the Red Sox and the Yankees were
Fielding 200 million dollar roided up
free agent teams okay so as far as I was
concerned teams like the Dodgers the
Yankees and the Red Sox couldn't
complain all the other teams could
complain but I'm a Red Sox fan so I
can't complain because of the ridiculous
advantage that we had because we all
have had all that money all right my
complaint
my complaint is
that no one is giving you [ __ ] about it
okay I had to sit and watch [ __ ] the
NFL and all of these guys these analysts
Steve Young all of these guys trashing
the [ __ ] Patriots calling us cheaters
all the [ __ ] time I'd listen to that
all the [ __ ] time over trumped up
[ __ ] [ __ ] charges even Spygate
with like the magnitude of that was
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was the first game
it was illegal to do that and you can
still have a camera up in the [ __ ]
Booth they just don't want it down on
the sidelines they feel it looks bad it
was an aesthetic thing that's all the
[ __ ] it was and we got ratted out by
[ __ ] Mangini
um who's the coach of the Jets who used
to [ __ ]
you know do it with the with the [ __ ]
Patriots
you know and we we got like 12 years of
[ __ ] for that you guys actually fixed a
[ __ ] World Series and there's a gag
order like nobody's talking about it
that's when it pissed me off if you've
noticed sir or ma'am I haven't talked
about it I haven't given a [ __ ] about it
like for the past five years it's now
that you guys are back into the [ __ ]
World Series and no one is saying like
well let's see you know this would be
great for them because the last time
they won a World Series there was the
whole you [ __ ] cheated scandal
that's what it is all right did you get
that in your recording device
if that doesn't sum up this the way the
world is right now
recording devices filming people and all
of this [ __ ] everybody's trying to get
everybody in trouble it's really uh
you know I always call it young people
like the rat generation I feel like
they're all like everybody's like that
now older people are like that everybody
just wants to try to get somebody in
trouble it's kind of funny too because
like the way we're wired
you know it's hard to get out of your
own head so like what what you see and
what your brain then tells you you saw
is the truth and no one can tell you
different you know and if you didn't see
it correctly
or more importantly if you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know
you're not gonna know that you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] because you're trapped
between your ears
so
that's why I just feel like people just
like film [ __ ]
and they feel like that they're like
proving something
and half the time they end up making
themselves
look more guilty than the person that
they're filming or I love when you they
just show like
um like take that Michigan State thing
or that Michigan player got the [ __ ]
kicked out of him he got stomped
right
um
the first clip of it looks like they
just jumped them and then I saw a
Barstool Sports thing where the guy was
skipping into where they were taunting
them
you know I mean that's got to be the
dumbest thing you could ever do and I
mean I'm not saying what they did was
right but like that kind of puts a
different spin on it like well that was
pretty [ __ ] stupid no
it's not something I would do
it's like you ever see somebody get
attacked
like
um
if somebody's like truly minding their
own business and are where they should
be that's when I feel bad for I always
feel bad if somebody gets attacked but
like if somebody you know
this is always once a year some [ __ ]
idiot has to go to the zoo and test the
animals and get too close and then they
find out you know how much faster or how
much stronger
they are and like there's like
you know you still look at it like that
somebody's dad that's somebody's brother
uncle or whatever but you're also kind
of like you're a [ __ ] idiot now other
people have to risk their lives to try
and save you
I mean that's basically the Coast Guard
I would love to get somebody on the
coast guard that anonymously
could come out here that's basically the
branch of the military strictly for
[ __ ] idiot civilians
now I'm not talking commercial fishermen
okay they got a job to do they got to
get out there and I mean the amount of
[ __ ] Weekend Warriors on boats
[ __ ] people not paying attention hey
there's a Riptide don't go out there
they [ __ ] get their dumb asses out
there I I can't imagine
I mean their job just has to be like you
know one [ __ ] idiot after you know
there's a hurricane please stay inside
don't go outside people go out there
with their [ __ ] surfboards or they go
out there you know I got to get my boat
out to sea or whatever the [ __ ] it is
they're trying to do
um and then they get themselves into a
shitstorm and some guys gotta fly a
[ __ ] helicopter into that [ __ ] and
somebody's got to repel out of it to go
down and pluck your dumb ass out of the
ocean
um
you know they always have all like those
videos on YouTube where they have like
you know dumbest criminals or like
Dumbest Drivers or whatever I bet the
[ __ ] Coast Guard could
could really uh
I would think the same way some sort of
whoever goes up and rescues those
lunatic skiers and snowboarders
you see those they they drop in just
it's not even a ski resort they just go
to a mountain and they just drop in and
they cause like a [ __ ] Avalanche and
now they're trying to get
now they're trying to like beat it down
the [ __ ] Hill
if you die doing that [ __ ] I always feel
like you know
do you remember when you were in the
waiting room outside like the
principal's office
and he would be in there you know
talking to another teacher about
something completely different but you
already knew that he knew what you did
and you remember that look when he would
just sort of look out
he'd look out at you and just for you
know give you a nice three second stare
that look I feel like that's what God
does when you show up sitting like
you're not next to have your life judge
but like he oh come on come on in you
know some old lady lets him in and then
he just kind of looks out the door and
gives you a three seconds
he's like
oh boy here we go
that's when you got to come and be like
I know I know
I know
it was stupid I I didn't think it was
gonna happen
I mean you should get mad at yourself I
mean you're the one who made me you know
maybe if you gave me a better brain I
wouldn't I wouldn't have done that
I wouldn't have added to your day here
having to sit through another
reel to reel if somebody's boring ass
[ __ ] life
um all right so anyway so does that
clear that up for you Astro fan
yeah I didn't give a [ __ ] I wasn't going
to look at you guys like
you were any worse than you know what
the [ __ ] we were doing but my thing is
you should get [ __ ] for it
you should get [ __ ] for what you did
because I thought I was being really
cool saying that having royed it up free
agents was on the same level of knowing
you know what whatever pitch that was
that they were hitting the breaking ball
you just knew that that pitch was coming
I mean that's
that's a level of advantage that
in hindsight really was beyond
okay but I had empathy for smaller
Market baseball teams
that you know like the Cleveland Indians
like the [ __ ] amount of
the Yankees the Red Sox the Phillies I
lost count of the amount of teams that
won World Series with
a monster Talent
you know Jim Tomy CC Sabathia Manny
Ramirez there was another uh pitcher in
there that was just a lights out [ __ ]
picture the fact that the Indians never
won one
is insane so that's that's where I was
coming from back then
um
but you know I still thought you know
you were going to get I was actually
sticking up for you thinking that you
were going to get a bunch of [ __ ] which
you did for a minute and then it all
went away and then that's when it pissed
me off all right Sam I'm done talking
about it all right [ __ ] ways to protest
yo Billy double time
I'm writing in to your fine podcast to
comment on protests
uh my kid is in the middle school and
one of the classes covered good ways to
protest the list was laughable
uh Slash creepy like why why would they
bring that in well I agree if they say
don't ever try to stop traffic
uh one of the effective ways to protest
according to this list was shouting
it went on to vaguely say that it's not
always a good idea but shouting can be
very effective in getting your point
across
it should have included footage of me
and my Idiot Friends arguing at a sports
bar
also on the list was sabotage all right
you know what I judged this too early I
don't know which [ __ ]
school they're going I kind of like this
school I told my kid if she got arrested
for sabotage I was going to testify
against her and use the school
distributed list as admissible evidence
so no one thought I was a bad parent she
knew I was kidding because I didn't
raise a psycho who thinks that generally
speaking
sabotage was a good idea
unless you're breaking into an Imperial
base with migs Mayfield uh Mayfield uh
Mayfield yeah yeah thanks for the free
podcast
yeah I mean
it's it's like anything man there's a
time and a place for yelling there's a
time and a place for sabotage
uh
it's all how you apply it
that's real that's kind of the art of
life
everything for the most part is on the
table
except reading a book written by a
rapist
uh an admitted rapist uh skinny shaming
hey Billy barbecue head
um I love that we're talking about
skinny shaming and then you're [ __ ]
immediately start treasuring I don't get
barbecue head
I'm trying to think about that I have a
ghost white head Casper the Friendly
Ghost head I don't know
Billy barbecue maybe it's just
alliteration barbecue head
uh wife and I are big fans and I've been
listening to the podcast for the last
six years thank you always cracking up
on the long camping road trips oh that's
awesome
you're out there road tripping
um anyways you're always on about fat
shaming but what about skinny shaming
I'm the youngest of three brothers and
ever since I could remember I've always
been called Skinny the skinny scrawny
kid my two older brothers used to make
my life a living [ __ ] hell growing up
punching kicking throwing [ __ ] getting
pushed off my bike you name it yeah yeah
that's what little brothers do uh too
skinny and weak to do anything back Mom
and Dad didn't care either when I
finally hit 18 I moved out with a few
boys a few of the boys and I lived the
batch of life for a few years it was the
same going out to try and pick up some
flange
uh chick said I don't know I don't know
flange I gotta look that one up never
heard f-l-a-n-g-e chicks said I'm too
skinny no muscle
I met my now wife at 22 I'm 36 now but
all my 20s I keep hearing the same old
[ __ ] you're too skinny you need to eat
more when I hit 30 I said [ __ ] it I'm
tired of this skinny [ __ ] I joined a gym
and started eating 3 000 calories a day
six years on them six one two fifty five
with 12 body fat now when I see my
brothers at my family gatherings Etc I
always threat
slash fake punch them as a joke and they
squirm like little [ __ ] [ __ ] haha
I know I can't keep this diet up forever
but I am slowing down but still keeping
active in my late 30s long story short
skinny slash fat shaming Works Bill keep
it up much love to you and your fam from
another Ginger drummer you [ __ ]
um
yeah being skinny sucks and being
scrawny you know
when you're younger
because all the chicks want to go for
the [ __ ] you know the Beefcake guys
but uh those guys usually end up being
fat [ __ ] with man tits
in the end so
you're sort of front end loading the
[ __ ] the same people trashing you you
will eventually be able to trash and
having a high metabolism and being
skinny is [ __ ] great
um it's actually a great thing I think
um
I don't think you need to go to the gym
too and eat like a bunch of calories and
put on a bunch of mussels I would go
martial arts
and they'd be that skinny dude that
[ __ ] somebody up you know
you're already skinny so it's just
nothing but bone it's like you got a
[ __ ]
you know you like you're like a [ __ ]
walking Shank
um
anyway uh robots filling prescriptions
oh my God what could go wrong here
you know what that's also like that's
like the um
I heard they're getting rid of umpires
this is all just for money
I feel at first it's just going to be
for money to replace people
and then
the next move
is they're going to try to make us feel
inferior
so we accept our new place in life
um
and then I think eventually they'll get
rid of us
that's that's how I think it goes
and we'll and and rather than rising up
against them we'll be too busy yelling
at each other
politically and and racially and all
that other [ __ ]
I will say I was at a hotel and this
[ __ ]
his [ __ ] uh
like robot cleaning thing came up and
we could not close the the we could not
close
the it over rode like
the elevator we had to ride down with it
should just [ __ ] tip the thing over I
don't know why I didn't it's like I'm
not riding down with that [ __ ] thing
and it was like sort of like I just
thought it was so [ __ ] creepy
people who work in [ __ ] corporations
I swear to God they they should all be
put down they're like they're like
[ __ ] sick animals
I think the only thing that fills them
up is just scaring people and creeping
people out and [ __ ]
like how much more [ __ ] cool can life
get it's like we have enough technology
just enough just stop
and all these [ __ ] Egghead scientists
they all end up working for sociopaths
you know right back to [ __ ] Albert
Einstein
even he fell into the same thing
um all right robots filling
prescriptions dear bill I work in
healthcare I.T
I don't know what i t means I looked it
up one time and I forget
um intensive
tracheotomy
let me see what what does it stand for
here we go let's look this up
what
does
i t
stand four it's probably going to stand
for a lot of things
let's see
yeah what does it mean in technology
Information Technology all right I work
in healthcare information technology
I was in a conference call with a senior
executive from a supermarket
slash Pharmacy retailer with 2200
locations in North America that starts
with the letter k
please don't read on air oh okay
um Roger I won't say anything
like all of corporate America
uh they want to automate everything they
can
he said that they are testing automated
machines to work in pharmacies and fill
prescriptions instead of humans he was
very excited to report that the error
rates by robots are way lower than
humans based upon data from their
existing Pharmacy Network he said he
could not reveal a deployment timeline
but was optimistic about three to four
years since you are putting in so much
good effort to stay healthy are you
concerned that our future medications
for blood thinners and other critical
medication for our golden years will
soon be managed by algorithms and
dispensed by automated machines
I've been to four of your shows and will
happily continue to pay for tickets oh
that's what a nice compliment thank you
best regards
um
I'm not worried as an old person I'm not
worried about robots I'm worried for you
younger people
and what your world is going to be
same thing with like climate and all of
that it's like
um you get to a certain age and you
realize it's not about you it's about
what you leave behind what are we
leaving behind and all of that stuff
and
[Music]
um
I don't know how to get out of this I
really don't
um
the only successful way to get out of
anything has always been violence
that's how this whole country came about
genocide and then a revolution a lot of
people [ __ ] died and then uh
you know
who would have thought
those robber barons of the 1800s the
influence that they still have
the game that they set up
and played so brutally effective
with just of like those heartless
[ __ ] people would just affect like
everybody
is just under the thumb of that like
there's no [ __ ] reason
for all all of this this it's I don't
know
I you know all you all you smart people
out there who can like
come up with these amazing things like
robots being able to
fill prescriptions can't you got you
know why because you get paid by
sociopaths can't you just come up with
something
that like
can figure out if somebody's a sociopath
and when you get like a hit then you
literally just have like a Hitman robot
there's a nice sci-fi movie
is like what if you didn't upset the
whole system is you just went out and
whacked the right people
would then the non-sociopaths
have the ability to be like
all right let's try to you know kind of
ease up here man everybody sort of Live
and Let Live you know man
um I don't know I don't have any answers
you know I just did the uh the Tim
Dillon podcast and I had a great time
and um
I already knew that that guy was super
funny but he is a deep thinker that guy
he thinks about big subjects
and um
he was asking me a lot of this stuff and
uh I was trying to be uh
I was trying to have hope
you know
because I I feel like I've had a really
good life and and I got to live
during a for the most part a good time
and I hope that when I'm gone that other
people get to have the same experience
and I just feel like this type of [ __ ]
with like putting all this money in
robots because you don't have to pay for
people because they have needs and they
complain when you abuse them
is uh kind of unsettling all right let's
get back to the comedy everybody oh geez
there
um flashed at work oh my God
uh hey Billy the bald-headed bastard I
need your advice I'm a 25 year old with
a shitty delivery job today while
listening to your podcast I pulled up to
a house in a gated community in the rich
part of town
as I'm looking for a package I see the
guy who I'm delivering to run up to me
I guess it's supposed to say in his
boxers I know super [ __ ] weird all I
wanted to do was try to find this
[ __ ] package as fast as I can so I
can get the [ __ ] out of there as I'm
grabbing the package I see him fiddling
with his dick a little [ __ ]
disgusting as I go to roll down
the window to hand it to him because he
was close enough to the door that I
can't open it
and what do you know his 65 year old
dick pops out
all I could say to him was what the [ __ ]
dude
I've seen a lot of weird [ __ ] when I'm
out delivering but nothing like this
this is just one of the reasons why I
hate my job and I'm kind of to the
breaking point yeah I would think of
[ __ ] 65 year old dick
good Lord some Vietnam era dick flashing
in your face yeah that would be annoying
uh I'm a college student so I know this
is only temporary but I'm not sure I can
take it anymore if you're in my shoes
what would you do would you stick around
knowing you only have a year left in
school or would you quit to find and
find a new job
uh please come to Boise on your next
tour I'm going there
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself a man with
hair oh you son of a [ __ ]
um
all right now why are you at your
Breaking Point
because it's a shitty job or because you
people keep you keep delivering to this
person
or was that the final straw
um
look if you're at your [ __ ] breaking
point you know I would figure out a way
to get another job you know what you
should get another job
because you want another job
this is kind of a good moment in life
where things aren't going the way you
want it to go
and
you need to build the right muscle
memory here which is if you're in
something that isn't working for you you
take the positive steps
to get out of that to get out of that
situation so um you're only 25 years old
so I think walking away from this job
and finding another one is not going to
financially ruin you
um it's not going to hurt you one way or
the one way or the other and I think you
know you went out there you didn't like
the job and then some 65 year old guy
shook his [ __ ] dick in your face or
whatever happened yeah I think you know
the line yet I I would say the line was
there and he went over it
and uh yeah
that's a good thing because I can tell
you what I would have done at your age
is I would have [ __ ] just I wouldn't
have done anything
I would have continued to work there now
if I had to deliver another package to
the guy I'd have the package ready and
what I would do is as I was driving up I
would frisbee it out at him
you know
because I was like all right
that's how I would handle that but I
think it's uh a really good thing for
you as a person
to have boundaries
um
I think everybody should have those and
you just have lines like hey you know
this this is the deal if you do this
this and this I'm cool if you do any of
these things I'm out and then you stick
and you stick to it so it sounds like
you want to
you're resigning yourself
to a year of [ __ ] misery
um
I don't want to jinx you but like I feel
like what could be worse than a job you
hate and then some guy shaking his
[ __ ] dick at you
I mean this there's got to be a better
job than that out there I would think
and you know what you actually speaking
of that I like you know a lot of people
saying like you know what hiring but
like nobody wants to work
ever since you know the uh the covet
thing nobody wants to work I love how
that's how it's processed
it's like maybe for the first time in
their lives they had time to just stop
and think and assess and see how fast
time's going by and seeing how they're
being treated
and they would like to have a better
life
I don't think people don't want to work
I don't think people want to be treated
the way that they're being treated
I think that that's more so I mean
there's definitely people who don't want
to work that would be me like right now
I don't want to work
[Laughter]
I'm a little burned out but like I know
when I get to these points that I just
have to take like a couple weeks off and
I'll I'll be fine
but like
um
I don't think that people like literally
don't want to work oh and there's
something else I wanted to post
out here there's there there's some
question that they're voting on like
vote no on 27 or 29 or something like
that
and it was talking how about how
one of those
um
Sports gambling sites
like because the company's based in New
York up in Boston like all the revenue
from the money that they make goes to
Massachusetts
and New York state of New York
and then they get all that tax revenue
so
to show how dumb it was
they make this commercial
they're going like yeah do you know that
all the all the gambling money goes to
blah blah goes to Boston and New York
and then they just have like these Joe
these actors playing like Joe six-pack
people from Boston and New York like oh
how dumb uh how dumb are they in
California and then they have this woman
going in Boston like hey Mark did you
know California is just a state full of
suckers and they got this guy in front
of Fenway Park like jumping up and down
like acting as though they get the money
like the people get the like the people
of Massachusetts the people in New York
get the money they don't
the governments get the money and then
the people that get the politicians into
the office
and get their projects to go through and
overcharge and all of that they get the
[ __ ] money
um I gotta post that commercial because
the uh
the lady actually she looks like you
know when I was growing up some [ __ ]
disheveled woman from Dorchester or
maybe up on the North Shore
um all right that is the podcast
everybody
um stomach growling here I gotta get
something to eat over there
um enjoy your week
don't take your dick out and shake it at
somebody uh
do you employ people treat them as human
beings please don't replace them with
robots
and uh I don't know I got nothing for
you go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in on
you on Thursday from what I heard
because my Center Ice package isn't
[ __ ] work and the Boston Bruins have
their best start in franchise history
and Brad Marchand came back six weeks
early
uh I'm loving it all right that's it
I'll talk to you later